that's great that's very nice
that is a night that is a uh
[Applause]
wow and one guy that's a pretty good
yeah
that guy just told us something very
important how are you thanks for being
here thank you so much you can't get
used to that right I mean I know
everything's going your way these days
but that is an insane don't go there
don't go there
you would know better than anyone what
are you talking about let me tell you
let's get down first of all to be fair
yes a half that reaction right now I
think was for me
so let's get down to brass tacks here
all right sure there's not a woman in my
life that I know well that hasn't
admitted to me at some point that she
has lustful fantasies about you
who are these women where
we're not talking elderly female
relatives am I wrong am I wrong yeah
crap seems to
yes now well that's that's very nice of
you to say and uh funny I'm not being
funny it's true well I appreciate it I
used to an ex-girlfriend of mine used to
want to watch your uh show in bed every
night and if I ever got a little handsy
right I'd get smacked and she would say
after Conan
you know that also implies that watching
me got you in the mood
string dance and you're like ah
I'm sorry I'll just shut up I will say
this though you guys look I mean you
guys I love you guys I'm a huge fan of
the show thank you so much
any like with your biggest fan right
really yeah but you guys look a lot
tougher in person than you do on TV you
know people don't know that people think
you guys could kick some ass yes we
could on TV we project this image I
don't know how this happens but uh I
seem weak and ineffectual you know but
in person asking safe safe that's the
meanest thing anyone's ever said
[Laughter]
but it's all ruse yeah exactly we're
tough guys yeah but let's talk about you
and then more about us okay and then
mostly about me
um
you of course uh have had so much
success uh in the last couple of years
and you're becoming such a big celebrity
and I see all these pictures of you
everywhere and I have to say I have
noticed I've seen many photographs of
you at Disneyland
and I've occurred to me the other day
you don't have kids you just seem to go
and a lot of the photos you seem to be
by yourself going to Disneyland and I
think that's fun but are you are you a
freak for Disneyland you love that place
um
I have a real love hate thing going on
with Disney okay all right let's talk
about it
I'm here to help you well it's it's it's
a slippery conversational slope so I
don't know if you want to go down there
I do they're dangerous people
well they're just
okay I'll give you an example of why I
love and hate them okay this I don't
know if this is true or not so I and I
do not want to get sued by Disney okay I
do not they're not contagious people
hey let stuff slide yeah yeah they go
real easy on people so this there is a
belief that Disney has been uh breeding
an army of cats
and they're not just ordinary cats they
have special set of skills they're like
Commando cats Commando cats and they
live in a barracks
a cat Barracks I don't know what you
call it uh like a cat Barracks sure sure
he's sleeping bunk beds sure they live
on the outskirts of the Park yeah and at
night when they close the park under the
cover of Darkness
these cats Ascend into the park and they
eat all the mice
cats are great at getting mice so maybe
that's true I don't know which is what I
love about Disney because that's because
they're so weird and they think of
everything right
and cats just know to come back in the
morning yeah and then they go back when
the sun comes up and they do it all
again I think it's so messed up about it
why I hate them is that the whole empire
of Disney is built on the back of one
Mouse
I didn't think of that
if her Mouse can't be safe there yeah
then where if you're a mouse and you go
into Disneyland you are not leaving
alive
and you think this is going to be the
best place in the world for you yeah you
put your forefinger gloves on you go to
have a good time it's a death sentence